il faut savoir que c'est la possibilité
pour près de 4 millions de
personnes ayant leur titre de séjour et
de travail en conformité avec nos
lois de vivre comme des
Français avec les mêmes droits au
travail à la protection sociale au
logement à
l'éducation sans tolérer aucune forme de
racisme le respect à la différence c'est
la possibilité d'exercer cette égalité
des droit en préservant son identité
culturelle sa manière de vivre et ses
traditions dans le cadre d'une société
pluraliste comme l' la société française
l'égalité ne signifie pas en effet
l'uniformité et la France qui est en
train de s'organiser et celle de la
variété multicolore des formes de vie
des choix d'organisation de sa vie
personnelle et non celle de la grisaille
de l'obligation et de l'uniformité